the inflation numbers came in this
morning and oh boy are they bad
inflation in the united states year over
year is now at 7.5
this is absolutely bonkers type data
this is the highest inflation number
that we have seen in over 40 years let's
go right to the charts what you can see
here is that the cpi inflation is at 7.5
percent the core inflation which takes
out a number of different items is still
at six percent this is bad news folks
then if we go and we look over the years
at what the hell has been going on with
inflation you can see that the consumer
price index for all urban consumers all
items in the u.s cities it is exploding
upwards we haven't seen inflation this
high since 1982. then if we go and look
around the world is this a u.s problem
or is it bad elsewhere the united states
is one of the worst countries in the
world what do i mean the u.s at 7.5
percent only poland russia brazil turkey
argentina and venezuela are worse
literally the u.s getting grouped in
with places with super high hundreds of
percent of hyperinflation the united
states has a problem and no one seems to
have a solution if we then go and we
look at exactly how this is breaking
down used cars are up 40
gasoline up 40 percent furniture up 20
things like peanut butter up 15
if we then even go and we look at new
cars those are up 12 as well what's not
on this list is things like food at home
or outside of the home up six and seven
percent all sorts of goods up very very
high it's because you cannot print
trillions of dollars and inject it into
an economy and not have negative side
effects
if we were to measure inflation based on
the real metrics not these manipulated
metrics not constantly changing the
methodology which the government does
the real inflation number's over 10
official inflation's at 7.5 percent but
the real inflation is much much higher
what do i mean here's a prime example
our friend charlie bolillo breaking down
something like rent
shelter specifically is the single
largest component included in cpi it
makes up 33
of the computational index but it's
being wildly understated it's only
currently being set at 4.4
but rent is up 18 over the last year and
home prices are up 19
the actual inflation in the united
states is much higher than seven and a
half percent they're messing with the
numbers and the official number that
they're telling you is not true go to
the store go try to buy items go try to
actually spend money in the economy
there has not been a seven and a half
percent increase it's well into the
double digits and the more they tell you
it's seven and a half percent and the
more that you realize that when you go
to the store you're seeing something
else the less trust that people have in
this data and the less trust that you
have in these institutions inflation is
the highest it's been in 40 years
something's got to change and if they
don't change it the poor are going to
get poor the rich are gonna get richer
and that wealth inequality gap is only
gonna widen